alors on dirait que je veux faire un
brushing et que j'ai 65 ans un excellent
début de vidéo mais attends c'est chaud
j'ai vraiment les cheveux de des
ossatures quand est-ce qu'on arrêtera de
parler de mes [ __ ] de cheveux vous
m'entendez ça fait neuf ans que ça dure
neuf ans que ça dure ça suffit
maintenant that look expenses c'est le
sobre et 10 sur lequel nous allons
naviguer aujourd'hui rejoignez-moi dans
les flots messieurs dames
accrochez-vous omar allons opter cette
mère je suis libre dans ce sombre et dit
on va trouver que des vidéos de trucs
qui sont arrivés et qu'on coûte est du
coup très cher à réparer ou de bêtise
commise par des humains dont les
conséquences sont énervés économiquement
on va relativiser sur le foie on a
renversé un petit truc son siège de
voiture sur le canapé un peu cher de
maman vous allez voir là là c'est du
vrai level de bêtises fermé sur un condo
il ya deux semaines aujourd'hui les
conduit d'alimentation des bouches à
incendie ont cédé regardez moi bien la
merde dans laquelle est ce type là bas
c'est aquaboulevard [ __ ] il peut
inviter des potes chez lui là c'est une
poule partie incroyable
regardez moi cette merde c'est un
ventilateur ou c'est un arrosoir je
comprends plus je rêve oui je chantonne
j'ai pas rêver il y avait bien
une qualif c'est vraiment le chien sur
l'image là où il ya du feu partout et
lui dit il ya un truc
oh là là et ce qui arrive c'est que ça
cool ça cool tellement fort il peut même
pas mettre de so2 contenaires aucun son
ne sera assez grand pour tenir longtemps
sous une telle quantité d'eau aux délais
ya logé d'un toboggan de dakwa boulevard
qui a été redirigé dans son grenier
directement c'est incroyable un
technicien a accidentellement activer un
canon de feu vulcan aucune idée de ce
que c'est et il a détruit à f 16 qui
était garée là af zeze mec incroyable
vraiment des jobs où les gars s'ils font
une bêtise
la conséquence à l'étaiement ciel déjà
et son licencié immédiatement un bout de
moteurs de boeing 777 est tombée pendant
le vol et a atterri dans un jardin
pardon mais a tancé breaking bad ou quoi
il ya une scène dans breaking bad ou il
ya ça et où en la voyant je me suis dit
bon vraiment tiré par les cheveux le
truc pas du tout où on arrive à cette
personne un bout d'avion atterri dans
ton jardin c'est bon non ces faits qui
auraient un cratère y aurait un truc
j'ai archers du mal à y croire
suis-je en train de faire berner je me
fait berner ce n'est pas son premier
rodéo
qu'est ce que c'est que cette merde à
temps c'est un truc où il ya des jets
privés qui se garent d'accord le niveau
d'exigence de cet endroit et genre
abuser c'est le luxe de ouf et ya un
camion qui a perdu son chauffeur qui est
blessé actuellement et qui fait la
toupie à 3 mètres d'un jet privé
il va se prendre le jet il va se prendre
la prochain tour c'est le jet oil mais
comment est la dette ça elle sait
qu'elle adore ça les gars j'ai un peu
peur de l'avion comme j'ai dû beaucoup
de prendre j'ai moins peur mais j'ai
quand même jeu quand même pas très
serein tant il ya des gens ils attendent
d'embarquer
ils sont posés ils ont pris c'est le
petit café à boire pendant la tente il
fait trop du bien avant de rentrer dans
l'avion ils font un psycho voltec vers
la fnath et piano ça c'est les gens qui
s'occupent de l'avion dans lequel je
vais monter la la refonte complète de
sonic a dû coûter très cher mais avec ça
c'est un truc qui me fascine c'est les
compagnies et nos voyageurs beaucoup de
gens qui bossent sur le même projet
beaucoup de gens très talentueux qui
plus est et ça coûte beaucoup d'argent
genre les mecs c'est des décisions
importantes et où est il fondé mesplède
de fou que personne n'a vu au sein de la
compagnie
avant que soit rendu public excusez moi
mais regardez-moi la gueule de sonic à
la basse quoi c'est un [ __ ] jeu
d'horreur le truc les eaux voulu le
faire un peu réaliste je sais pas
pourquoi mais sauf qu un hérisson
quand tu veut coller sa tête sur un truc
humanoïdes ça marche pas du tout il faut
le faire mignon et le kawaii zélus faire
les gros yeux et c'est le lycée et dans
le genre il ya apple qui a fait 1 me
plaît comme ça que je trouve abuser il
avait sorti une nouvelle souris sans fil
et le trou pour mettre le câble pour
charger la souris sans fil qu elle a
plus de batterie il était sous la souris
ça veut dire que quand tu avais plus de
batterie tu pouvais plus bosser alors ça
c'est extraordinaire
dans le genre erreur qui a coûté très
cher c'est incroyable il ya un livreur
de pizza aux états unis et livre des
pizzas à un truc qui vend et loue des
voitures et la commande y en a pour 43
dollars en arrivant il eut fils 50
dollars lui il a pas de quoi faire le
change
ils le disent it's ok le livreur est
content il a eu sept dollars de
pourboire ipar et puis les gars qu'il a
livrée appelle la pizzeria et le patron
du livreur pour lui dire et nous a pas
rendu la monnaie et nous a volé 7 $ on
veut qui les ramène c'est scandaleux
c'est honteux
sauf que la version du livreur de pizza
c'est qu'ils lui ont laissé
volontairement 7 dollars de pourboire
quoi qu'il en soit le livreur de pizza
il se fait défoncer par son boss et il
retourne au truc de ventes automobiles
pour l'heure rome 17 dollars de surplus
taddei deçà caroline ben non car ma ce
que vous vous êtes voir salik tout
internet voit cette vidéo
les gens se disent mais c'était gros
chien de la casse ces gens là à traiter
un livreur comme ça ils ont craqué leur
slip du coup il met un milliard de
review négatives sur le compte google de
cette entreprise
du coup le business de ce mec là bas ils
chutent plus personne n'y va ils vont
beaucoup moins de friture etc
et en plus de ça les gens sur le web il
ouvre une cagnotte pour ce livreur de
pizzas en soutien et il ya eu plus de
dix mille dollars de dons c'est génial
quand des mecs qui sont 10 respecte à
fond ce fonds car ma is et la gueule
comme ça c'est incroyable
l'alcoolique qui est en moi fleur oh là
là le mec il a une cave à vin là dedans
il ya forcément plein de bouteilles qui
coûte vraiment cher jean plusieurs
centaines d'euros qu'est-ce qui peut mal
tourner
où
excusez moi mais le rythme des
bouteilles on dirait qu'elles ont un
cerveau et qu'elles veulent juste
provoqué ce gars vas-y stéphanie gb
après je ne me plains pas je vous jure
jury le lécher une sole jour et léché et
aspirer l'entièreté du sol
j'ai aucun prix avec l'alcool qui doit
compter mais enfin monsieur c'est pas
comme ça qu'on navigue avec un yacht à
trois étages qu'est-ce que vous
fabriquez cap 8 m
moi je pense que je meure instantanément
d'une rupture d'anévrisme si genre j'ai
fait la bêtise qui a mené le yacht a
coulé quoi mec c'est horrible vous
pensiez adopté un malinois ces adorables
et malinois ils sont géniaux ses chiens
je parie que ce propriétaire d'une
porsche à reconsidérer son adoption
après avoir enfermé son malinois dans
son garage pendant un petit moment
mais attends mec c'est un malinois ou
une scie sauteuse qui l'adopté je
comprends pas genre un chien sept
manches la toile de la voiture mais
c'est incroyable
et quand tu as oublié que tu t'égares
est au dessus de ta place de parking
ascenseur
ah ouais je comprends grave moi aussi
j'ai des fois je me gare sur ma place de
parking ascenseur
je les gars c'est bien un truc que j'ai
appris en grandissant au-delà du fait
qu'être méchant c'est méchant
à l'époque quand jouer à gta iv je me
prenais plein trucs sur la route sauf
que tous les trucs s'envoler sauf les
armes quand je me prenais un arbre c'est
moi qui m'en volet qui me faisait
éjecter de la voiture et je rage et je
me disais mais c'est trop mal fait
pourquoi ils ont fait ça c'est n'importe
quoi alors là la developer de merde
c'est 100% vrai et je les réalise et
traita en vrai c'est assez évident que
c'est vrai regardez ce qu'un arbre fait
à ta voiture ça rigole 0 peut rester mon
petit coup de gueule contre les armes
maintenant continuer de produire de
l'eau de et de permettre d'être en vie a
pas de souci assez génial en 98 à
honduras
il ya un pont qui a été construit au
dessus de la rivière show lutter cas
sauf qu'il ya un ouragan qui a décalé la
rivière et cette insolente de rivière
elle commence maintenant pile après le
pont ouais enfin ceux ci n'y a pas que
la rivière qui a bougé il n'y a plus
aucune route il reste rien c'est
incroyable quand la planète troll c'est
incroyable la mauvaise pédales
ça nous est tous arrivé les gars d'être
surpris en appuyant sur l'accélération
parce que en fait on était encore en
marche arrière ou omar chaban on dira
pas que certains ont défoncé lors qu'ils
à cause de ça mais on se comprend
qu'est-ce qui se passe il touche le sol
très bizarre
bah ça monte trop du coup le but c
c'est elle et si vite on est passé d'un
petit problème à un problème majeur
seulement quatre secondes mecs ça fait
trop bas dès qu'il ya une situation de
crise comme un mauvais move et trois
secondes suffisent à passer d'une
situation bof à une situation critique
ah ça c'est la crise quand tu vis en
norvège était oublié de fermer la
fenêtre de son bureau
vive le vent vive le vent vive le vent
d'hiver tout le monde alors faites
attention parce qu'à pas besoin de vivre
en norvège pour que ça t'arrive mois à
paris j'ai oublié de fermer un velux
chez moi et c'est tombé le jour où il a
le plus plu de 2017 quand je suis rentré
chez moi il y avait une mare au milieu
de mon salon d'ailleurs c'est vrai qu'en
voyant les images c'est moins vénère que
ce que ce que je pensais
mais moi au moment où ça m'est arrivé
franchement je me disais à tout moment
il ya deux trois canards qui arrivent et
qui s'installe dans mon appart quoi dans
cette mare des deux porsche hausser
encore quelqu'un qui a fait un créneau
sachez que j'ai une empathie incroyable
pour les gens qui galèrent à se garer ou
à sortir leur place de parking parce que
ça a été mon cas j'ai fait partie de ces
gens là le convoi de ré vidéo à l'époque
je cherchais ma première voiture je sors
de mon parking pour la toute première
fois je braque un peu trop tôt je racle
le poteau femme porte hier c'était ma
toute première expérience de parking
avec ma caisse ça m'a traumatisé les
gars du coup j'ai une énorme empathie
pour les gens qu'on voit là je suis plus
proche d'eux que de vous là sachez le
drac est trop tôt aulas
mais qu il a défoncé la voiture de
derrière
art mauvais move et trois secondes
suffisent à passer d'une situation bof à
une situation critique
what c'est une dépanneuse qui est tombé
avec la caisse qu'elle transportait et
est ce que la dépanneuse de la
dépanneuse va tomber ce serait
extraordinaire
je n'en mets les gars rire du malheur
des autres
quel plaisir quand même non mais c'est
vrai est franchement qu'est ce qu'il a
pu se passer à
il ya un vieux feu de palettes d'une
tristesse sans nom comment ça peut
escalader de ou flan je comprends même
pas mais non attends mais ils se font
trop chier les pompiers dans le pays la
question quoi un petit feu de palettes
en bois au milieu d'un parking vide
envoyé trois camions légal et toute
unité par l'aide quand elle est donc
apparemment les robots policiers sont
très mal programmés pour prendre les
escalators [ __ ] j'ai hâte que ça
arrive ça en france qui est des robots
comme ça agent je trouve ça trop drôle
phare je rigolerai moins quand ils
mettraient une giga mans mais avant
savent jeu sympa les robots c'est
honteux mais je suis sûr et leurs amis
une amende en plus je suis sûr et
certain et ce au prix une amende il les
a suspecté de l'avoir fait tomber
ok
[Musique]
quelqu'un te veut du mal et à trouer
studio c'est obligé c'est vraiment au
jeu excusez moi j'arrête je suis désolé
je vais un peu loin je suis désolé chien
le troisième une troisième ces trois
heures
ouais
[Applaudissements]
quand même pas une sixième couronne 6e
comme à peine 6e huawei
et bien messieurs dames j'ai pris un
maximum de plaisir à voir que certaines
bêtises sont bien plus relou que les
miennes ça fait du bien quand même
merci à vous d'avoir regardé subtil so
british voilà je pense que c'était un
bon message là de se moquer un peu des
autres ça fait du bien je vais continuer
un peu date d'instaurer des valeurs cool
et françaises dans une époque je les
gants je suis désolé mais on a bien
relativisé aléas très vite portez vous
bien mes petits squido ça vous a ému la
défense vous appelez multi suizo sexe
émouvant est un peu ridicule
à bientôt lice quiz hausse
[Musique]
à